Aéroport Montréal-Trudeau,uxuxux
fixés sur l'écran des arrivées,
Stéphane Lague est nerveux.
Après des semaines de démarches,
finalement à accueillir Dmytro,
Oksanaleleleur fille Dominika.
Ils les ont rencontrés sur ce
groupe Facebook où les réfugiés
venir au Canada peuvent échanger
avec des Canadiens prêts à
les héberger.
- J'ai hâte, je suis content.
On regardelalalala télé et
on a deux choix dans la vie :
soit on change de poste t t t te
pas ou on s'implique et on dit :
"faut faire quelque chose".
- Procédures d'immigration,
plus tard, ils arrivent enfin.
(paroles indistinctes)
La famille est crevée après
Cracovie, Barcelone et Montréal.
Dmytro était en Pologne
quand la guerre a éclaté et
il a décidé de ne pas retourner
ils ont une valise etdeux petitr
le gouvernement du Québec,
on leur a donné une liste
de ressources communautairesnsnn
d'une carte d'assurance-maladie
et on a pris leurs coordonnées
pour des cours de francisation.
en route vers cette nouvelle
vie. On s'est donné rendez-vous
quelques jours plus tard.
Le temps d'assister à une autre
rencontre marquante à Dorval.
Celle de deux enseignants
qui ont réussi à faire venirquqs
de l'Université de Karkhiv.
(exclamimimimimimimimimimimimims
Ukrainiennes d'une dizaine
à arriver grâce aux contacts
de Martin Carrier, qui a déjà
MARTIN CARRIER, chargé de coursM
- On est en fait très fiers
d'
Ça a été énormément d'embûches
et on est évidem
très heureux de les recevoir.
MARYNA KHRENNIKOVAlqlqlqlqlqlqle
magnifique et c'est vraiment
très important pour nous.
- L'Université paiera
leur hébergement au moinspopopo.
- C'est avant tout un geste
humanitaurururururururururururu.
C'est un geste, je vous dirais,
de solidarité envers
l'Université de Karkiv
- Je pense que Montréal,
c'est plus cool que d'autres
c'est plus important etusususust
d'étudier tout en français
mais pas en anglais.
- Nous les avons revues deux
jours plus tard sur le campus
en science politique commencent
à découvrir leueeeeeeee
et s'organisent avec beaucoup
d'aide.
- Tout le monde parle avec nous
et ils disent : "Salut! Comment
ça va? Si c'est normal, est-ce
quc'est vraiment, vraiment gent.
dedededededededededededededededt
parfois oublier, juste un pe
les nouvelles de l'Ukraine et
l'inquiétude d'avoir une famille
- Seulement, je ne regarde pas
vraiment très, très difficile.
- Maryna sait que Karkhyv,
la veille et qu'il y a eu
plusieurs morts. Elle-
a dû fuir les bombes.
parce que... c'est la guerre.
C'étcicicicicicicicicicile.
Est-ce que je peux pas répondre
à cette question, s'il vous
- Derrière les sourires,
qui ne s'effaceront pas.
Mais leur vie, qui a basculé
en deux mois, leur offre
au moins
♪ ♪ ♪
Pour la famille de Dmytro,
ce noua a a a a a a a a a a a ae
de Stéphane à 25 kilomètres
de Montréal sur la rive-sud.nenr
première Pâques au Québec,
et Domika, qui aura 6 ans
la semaine prochaine, a déjà
Les deux familles semblent
à l'aise
même complices.
- Ça se passe très bienÉvidemmet
de vie à 180 degrés pour eux.
Donc, on e......................
- - - - - - - - - - - - Dmytro s
et Oksana, pour l'instant,
utilieieieieieieieieieieieieiei)
- Déjà, ils passent parfois
- Ça, c'est ma femme.
(rires)
- Ils passent aussi, parfois,det
la générosité de leurs hôtes.
(en anglais)uiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiur
financier, insiste plutôt su
la générosité de ses proches.
Bientôt, leurs intntntntntntntn.
- On a ramassé, jusqu'à date,
une laveuse-sécheuse,
on a eu des meubles pour meubler
- Il a même tro
pour Dmytro qui a hâte
de travailler. En attendant,
s'informe régulièrement detitit.
Dmytro et moi, vendredi passé,
dededededededededededededede
so e e e e e e e e e e e e e e t
des missiles qui passait
au-dessus de sa tête.
- Dmytro aimerait faire
Leur vie sera maintenant ici.
"On doit regarder vers l'avant
beaucoup d'opportunités, ici",n.
Dominika, qui a déjà son nouveau
sac,cocococococococococococococ.
Comme elle, comme Oksana,
Dmytro, comme Maryna ou
Anastasiia, ils sont aujourd'hui
à avoir fui la guerre, avec,
devant eux, une destinée qu'